[Music]
you didn't see me but here I am
cardboard cutouts are definitely still
funny okay and while I'm at it I am
definitely not running out of original
ideas
tell him Danny he's out of ideas again
Danny for [ __ ] sake we practiced this
okay I'm not I'm not running out of
ideas
Danny you're the new Danny now that's
right tell him which I'm Danny now
socket I've been doing this job for a
while that I'm running out of ideas and
the thing that I that I've been doing is
I I tend to take jokes and just keep
going with them and kind of go too far
and then and then I've done a bit later
people start asking wait it is
is he a Nazi come on I upload videos
every single day all right
and it's not like six years of doing
YouTube has made me run run dry of ideas
that's not what's happening here
BuzzFeed BuzzFeed is running out of
ideas I've got plenty
I got catalogs and sacks of ideas what's
your inner potato has must be done that
one I don't think so
wait they have what is the Simpsons 15
things with hedgehogs that looks like
hedgehogs are you kidding me are you
kidding me how is this possible okay
well all right we're gonna have to think
a little harder here okay because I'm
not out of ideas and let me prove this
once and for all
you might be cleaning your penis wrong
god dammit god dammit huh so in case you
didn't know you should be cleaning your
penis pretty much every day do you clean
it every day I think it's time that we
finally acknowledged that gifts are now
a hate symbol
good job BuzzFeed you did it because
every time I see these I want to die I
really really just want to make better
videos I know no one's gonna believe me
when I say that but I am trying okay so
yeah I can come up with ideas but I want
to do stuff that I haven't done before I
want to do something different and I
want it at the same time make other
people but like the old stuff happy and
it's it's a it's a it's a juggle it's a
jug it's hard but I think it's possible
in a trying to try to handle it the best
way I can but in the end if it seems
like I'm not coming up with ideas I just
want to try out different stuff I made a
Facebook post saying that I am hiring
and a lot of people took it the wrong
way and and and thought that I was sort
of like replacing myself and and taking
a step back or something like that I
have no intention of doing that
whatsoever I don't mean to keep talking
about the whole media thing but the the
last piece of the puzzle is sort of that
didn't really come out in the media was
rebel mode which was the company that I
was working on and that got shut down
and it's something that I've been
working on for three or four years and
it really sucked I think that's probably
the worst thing with this whole thing
going down I think it's rebel mode but
it wasn't really mentioned in the media
I guess it's not as important because I
never talked about revenue because rebel
mode never really got to where to a
point where I was really happy with it
so I didn't until then I kind of wanted
to keep it in the back but literally the
last three or four years it's I've been
doing YouTube and trying to run this
business that
you know doesn't exist anymore yeah it
sucks but I think it doesn't in the long
run it won't really matter but at the
same time my point with all this is that
now I'm hiring because I want to do more
stuff and that's never going to replace
what I'm doing between us in this
channel it's basically this channel is
running at its maximum capacity alright
I don't have videos ready in advance
this [ __ ] is running daily okay and it's
a lot of challenges but with doing daily
content it's stupid I really shouldn't
be doing it I really really should just
[ __ ] go back and upload twice a week
or some [ __ ] and then take a step back
but I still really really love that
daily challenge the daily grind of just
being like hey I'm gonna make a video
today no matter what and sometimes it
really works and sometimes it doesn't
that doesn't mean I'm running out of
ideas god damn it but basically now that
revenue is gone there's a gap for me to
do other things there's a whole opening
thing part of me really just wants to
feed more into the YouTube channel I
think that's a better idea for me to
spend my time with also please don't
apply to the job because we have way too
many applicants and connections
just please don't stay away I don't need
you so yeah long story short I'm not out
of ideas
oh I got one right now Leonardo DiCaprio
might be a human puppy that's a good
idea damn it damn it bus feed I'm sick
of your [ __ ] how the [ __ ] do you make
this many articles please don't take
what I say too seriously
I feel like I feel like honestly I need
one of those South Park things in front
of the videos now where it's like don't
take anything I say take seriously
whether you're a fan or not it's not a
good idea
I mean it is for you not for me so just
don't just don't do it I guess a lot of
people speculating like after all this
that I'm gonna
step down or some [ __ ] like that
especially I noticed that with the
Facebook post
I'm not believe it or not behind this
[ __ ] character I'm I'm more
passionate than ever to be making videos
and I'm I'm really really excited about
it and I don't want you to get the wrong
idea
so sorry I make too many jokes sometimes
I realize that's a problem now for sure
and I'll try and try my best to make
things more clear in the future I don't
know I don't know how to get past this
to be honest but all I can say for now
is there's a lot of exciting stuff
coming out already working on some new
projects and I can't wait to share them
with you and until then I hope my videos
will suffice something that I realized
especially these last couple of weeks is
how incredibly lucky I am to be here to
be making these videos how lucky I am to
every single day do what I love it's
something that I'm so incredibly
grateful for and no matter what that
that just means everything to me and I
know that wouldn't be possible without
you guys watching me so thank you for
watching and I hope I can do even better
I'm trying I am do you wanna
do this brofist
it's a white one